in high school I used to charge boys to
have like phone sex with me and stuff
just kind of been like this but I'm here
to be pornography is everywhere behind
closed doors many people may be
well-acquainted with sex workers but out
in the open
it's a taboo topic sex workers are often
judged for their career choice but who
are they when the cameras are off we
invited strangers from around the world
to come online and ask a cam girl
anything hi my name is Sharon and I am a
cam girl um so just to get started how
exactly would you define your job I log
on to a camp site every Monday through
Friday for four hours at a times 20
hours a week and I talk to people and
make money especially right now have you
seen a few convinces like Hezekiah since
coded Viking yeah definitely so last
week was probably one of my best weeks
that I've had in 2020 so does that end
up being like fairly lucrative it's like
your full-time gig for sure I do not do
I don't have like a vanilla job or
anything like that
I can make six figures a year on cammy
whether it's in a page show where I get
paid for a minute or they're tipping me
everything that they give me I get a
percentage from do you have a dedicated
space for candy that's separate from the
rest of your life so I have my camera I
have like this right here which is where
I care I may be a son closet where I get
ready I have a whole wall full of toys
like what is the weirdest request you've
ever gotten from someone there I can
write a book on that feeling cops on
there cam and their cop car and
seeing guys state baseball bats places
very large things I used to have this
customer who would come like every week
he would turn around and face the cam
and he would like who he would turn back
around he would take it and he would eat
it he would ejaculate just by eating it
and like not touching anything and I've
never seen anything else like that it's
a fetish and I really hate kink shaming
but that's that's just extreme right how
do you set boundaries with clients like
I understand like being a cam girl you
are like behind a camera and everything
but there are some certain aspects that
are kind of scary
I don't do every request and every cam
chef there's a lot of people who come on
and ask for racial play that is
something that I'm just not comfortable
with I don't do that if someone comes
into my room and I don't like what
they're saying or I don't like what
their fetishes I can just block them and
kick them out do trans women as well as
african-american women we see the same
opportunities in your field profession
as Caucasian white women do maybe as far
as painting and things and such
privilege is in every industry and in
everything and I am NOT blind or
ignorant to mine trans women and
african-american women do have a harder
time in my industry making more money
that should some of you know some of
their complaints and it's 100% real
do you ever want kids all my throughout
my life I always knew that I never
wanted children it just wasn't the type
of person I was now I think about it
because you know I've been with my same
person for years now though I do wonder
on how my lifestyle and such is going to
change if I do decide to have a child
how old you think you explain that to a
child that is like mommy what do you do
I have some friends who are very very
open with it and there are some women
that I know that just hide it I do want
my child to respect everyone and to be
open and to know but I understand that
when they get older and they
start going to high school is when kids
can start being mean and start like
bullying them and stuff
so it's they're a partner in the same
industry as you or now
no he's civilian he does he has regular
stuff regular life he doesn't even have
any type of social media or anything
like that is just really normal so do
you consider your relationship open no
we're very monogamous I don't make
content that I share with other people
are is girl-girl content and it is only
for filming I don't sleep with girls
outside of filming yeah he doesn't sleep
with anyone else at all period did you
feel any pushback from other people in
your life like your family or friends
when you decided to go into the industry
at first of course my jobs kind of like
why you can do so much like why should I
majored in law minored in psychology I
made the Dean's List every semester but
it was always like in the back of my
mind knowing what I wanted to do like
I've always been a sexual being very
interested and poor and very interested
like that's what I want to do recently
I've noticed that there's been like a
lot of popularity only pins has that
affected your work lately for me I've
that's part of my income half of my
income is camming and the other half is
only fans as my snap as custom videos or
clip sites but I I do feel bad that a
lot of girls kind of hopped on it as
maybe a trend or a way to make money
fast and they weren't planning on
getting in the adult industry and at the
end of the day that's gonna be on the
Internet and what's on the internet
can't be burned and so I just really
wish that girls would like think about
it before they decided to put themselves
on the internet like that a rhythm an
article prepping for this that webcam
girl described herself as like a
therapist for some of her clients
because they were able to be vulnerable
in front of someone for like the first
time do you relate to that in any way I
have clients who they would never tell
their partner or future partners what
they're fed
and what they personally like because
they may be too embarrassed I have men
who come in and just like we'll need
that release you know maybe they're
married and have kids but it's not going
so well and he just needs to come in and
talk to somebody who's not gonna judge
them about it I think that a lot of men
use cam models as an outlet to be able
to express things that they couldn't
express to people who just really know
them what do you think is really
misunderstood about the industry we work
in by the general public that sex
workers this is you know their last
resort or they're doing it because it's
trendy or they're I drug addicts or you
know things like that there are some
women and people who are just in sex
work because they want to because this
is what they like to do I wish that
people would understand that more of
like oh this girl she must have daddy
issues no I just really love what I do
do you see yourself kind of doing this
for a long period of time what do you
see yourself doing as in a career I
believe about the adult industry is
where I am supposed to be and honestly
if I wanted to do this until I was 60 70
years old there are women who do that
and they excel and they do really well
but as far as being a performer for the
rest of my life I don't think so I think
I'm going to venture on into owning a
cam studio and training camp girls and
stuff like that I think I'm just gonna
be a boss lady one day thank you so much
this was really cool thank you so much
like I hope you have a great day stay
safe thank you so much for talking to me
this is a great it was really nice to
meet you bye thank you okay